c'est l'information du week-end Régine
le centre hospitalier de Versailles
était victime d'une cyberattaque victime
d'une cyberattaque samedi soir l'hôpital
André Mignot de Versailles a déclenché
son plan blanc qui permet de prendre des
mesures exceptionnelles en cas de crise
vers 21h des ordinateurs affichés un
message concernant des informations
dérobées pour limiter la propagation sur
le réseau la direction à couper
l'ensemble du système d'information une
cellule de crise a également été ouverte
on écoute le témoignage du maire du
chêne Rocancourt au micro de Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude l'idée c'est
d'accompagner l'équipe qui est en
gestion de crise le temps qu'il faudra
donc sans doute jusqu'à Noël pour
s'assurer qu'ils ont l'ensemble des
moyens donc des hier le ministre de la
Santé François Bron est venu indiquer
que le Samus zonal donc le SAMU de
France était venu apporter des hier soir
des moyens notamment en matière de
biologie pour revenir pallier les les
défaillances liées à l'attaque donc on a
en terme matériel on n'aura pas trop de
soucis je pense que la solidarité va
fonctionner derrière il faut qu'on
s'assure que les personnels la durée
l'ARS Île-de-France Agence Régionale de
Santé invite les patients à composer
directement le 15 en cas d'urgence
l'établissement peut aussi compter sur
la solidarité régionale certains
patients ont été transférés dans
d'autres établissements franciliens
comme il explique Alexandre moquedet
directeur de la communication au centre
hospitalier de Versailles
par précaution sur des patients qui
étaient particulièrement instables étant
donné que le système d'information était
indisponible pour faire le suivi et la
surveillance de ces patients au central
qui n'étaient pas possible on a préféré
les transférer une plante a été déposée
dimanche à l'hôpital et le parquet cyber
de Paris a été saisi sur ce dossier là
ainsi qui est l'autorité nationale en
matière de sécurité et de défense des
systèmes d'information va réaliser un
suivi des conséquences de l'attaque